[Music]  birds here at Bankers Life Fieldhouse  close up and his three this time goes in  the  confidence doctors not be living  position Arriba George wanted to shoot  it passes it after Williams star the  qualifier  if I'll behave then then it comes and  gets him back through time same school  120 or more Williams escapes Carroll in  the lane three-point shot is gone it's  by George repeating the shot clock now  George looks for three or that's what  they can be  he was screaming to him to get up got  back halfway through down to Ted knap  George a long three  but you see what all is  the pet that solid defensively here you  didn't warn gets there when it gets  there Paul George's has so much  confidence because prior to that he just  the bottle